Have you been able to get
your COVID-19 jab yet?
Many countries are rolling out
the COVID-19 vaccines
so that the pandemic will be over
and we can get back to normal.
If you’ve never had COVID-19,
your body doesn’t know
how to fight it off.
Vaccines help train
your immune system
to recognize the virus
and be ready to attack.
But as we all have
different immune systems,
we respond differently
to the vaccine and the virus.
Having side effects
has nothing to do
with the effectiveness of the vaccine.
So let's see what's going on
once you get the jab.
Congratulations!
You’ve just had your first dose
of the COVID-19 vaccine.
For this episode,
we'll be focusing on messenger RNA,
or mRNA vaccines.
Once it enters your body,
the mRNA vaccine
instructs your cells
to create a spike protein.
This simulates
part of the SARS-CoV-2 viral structure
and tricks your body
into believing that it's been infected.
The spike proteins will then
head to the surface of your cell.
Your immune cells will detect
these proteins that don't belong
and begin making antibodies.
If you happen to catch the virus
in the future,
these antibodies will attach
to the spike proteins on both
your infected cells
and the coronavirus.
This will mark them
for immediate termination
by your immune cells.
To be clear,
the mRNA does not change your DNA
in any way.
Hear what I say?
Once the spike proteins are made,
your body destroys the mRNA.
Five minutes after your vaccine shot,
you'll feel some soreness in your arm.
To be safe,
the Centers for Disease Control
recommends you stay
at the vaccination site
for at least 15 minutes
in case of a severe reaction.
While it's rare,
you could have anaphylaxis,
which is an immediate allergic response.
It causes a series of symptoms
such as hives or swelling.
Thankfully,
trained healthcare personnel
will be available
at every vaccination site
to treat you immediately
with epinephrine.
And according to the CDC,
you have a greater chance
of being struck by lighting,
around one in 500,000,
than having an allergic reaction.
Four hours after your vaccine,
you could feel nothing at all.
Lucky you.
But you could also get a slight headache
or a low-grade fever
and feel tired.
This is perfectly normal
and is a sign that your immune system
has kicked into action.
At this point,
you may experience mild symptoms
as your body acclimatizes to the vaccine.
You might feel tired and feverish.
Be sure to get some rest
and take the day off work if you need to.
After about 48 hours,
you should start to feel normal again.
So let’s keep going.
Okay, if you got the Pfizer
or Moderna vaccine,
you’d need to get
your second booster shot
three to four weeks after the first dose.
Your immune system
would be stronger than the first time.
But let’s see how it goes next.
After your second dose,
you might feel crummy again.
You could feel tired
feverish
and you might get the chills.
These reactions are more common
after the second dose of the vaccine.
But they’re mainly mild to moderate
and usually go away in a day or two.
And two weeks after your second shot,
you’d be fully vaccinated
against the COVID-19 virus.
So far, the Pfizer-BioNTech vaccine
has been 95% effective
at preventing COVID-19 illness.
In either case,
the vaccine can prevent
hospitalization
and death
in people who have gotten sick.
So getting a vaccine
is your safest path
to protect yourself,
your family
and your community against this virus.
It could also help reach herd immunity
by having vaccinated people
act as a barrier between
non-vaccinated people
and those who have been infected.
This video was a collaboration
between Nucleus Medical Media
and the What If Channel,
where we usually dive
into hypothetical scenarios
on the human body,
humanity,
the planet
and the cosmos.
Check out our channel
by visiting the link
in the description below.